Morris Brown College says we're going to
bring back the masks and here's what
they said they said the mask mandate is
a precautionary move for the next 14
days it's being reported by WSB-TV does
that sound familiar two weeks that's
what she said they're actually saying at
Morris Brown College hey hey we're not
no no we're not bringing the mask the
mask's back oh hey man we're not
bringing the coveted measure we're just
it's just two weeks to slow the spread
oh shoot we can't say two weeks if we
say two weeks they'll maybe they'll
remember that we did this exact same
thing last time ah let's say 14 days
yeah yeah they won't they won't put two
and two together they're not even
changing the script